and start all right uh welcome to the
ddps seminar everyone before we
introduce our invited speaker let's go
over some rules and Logistics first of
all please you mute yourself during the
talk unless you have questions if you
have questions you are welcome to mute
and ask otherwise please use chat room
to post your questions so that we can
address them in create a session at the
end second today's ddk seminar is open
to external audiences therefore no
classified discussion is allowed so
please watch out finally The Talk today
will be recorded and uploaded in our
YouTube channel that's about it now let
me introduce our speaker today
it is an honor a great honor to host
Michael Brenner who is the the Michael
cronian professor of Applied Mathematics
and professor of physics at Harvard
University where he has taught and done
research since 2001. he's also a
principal scientist at Google research
where he works at the borderline of AI
and science
today Michael will talk about scientific
uses of automatic differentiation which
is an exciting topic please enjoy and
expect a wonderful talk now without
further Ado let me pass the button to
Michael by asking one random question as
usual today's random question is what is
one goal you have for the near future
so okay so the goal for the near future
would be to accomplish something I I
this talk is you you know there's lots
of potential um but I would really like
to turn it into something
you know something concrete
yeah something it's something that's not
a model problem that would be my goal oh
the real problem we have a lot of real
problems you guys have a lot of real
problems that's right you know a real
problem we're not where the answer
actually matters
um so that maybe I don't know so maybe
you guys can help this is my actual goal
awesome okay a lot of uh sooner we can
do it the better we are right so noisy
yeah awesome okay the stage is yours
Michael yeah okay thanks everybody so
thanks for having me I I um so I should
admit up front that this talk has too
many slides in it and um but what I want
to try to do today is just give a broad
idea which um I'm sure will not be new
to many of you but I just to sort of
tell you to sort of explain the way that
we've been thinking about these problems
and then I'll dive into some examples
and I'll try to I'm going to try to
spend most of my time on one of the
topics that's in this set of slides
which is on
um using automatic differentiation to
learn algorithms for pdes which I think
is probably more synergistic with things
that are happening there but if there
are other interests that people have I'm
happy to modify I don't have to get
through this in any way so okay so the
Preamble goes like this so many of us
have been inspired by advances in
machine learning which gives rise to you
know lots of interesting mathematical
questions I mean like you know why do
large
um you know neural network machine
learning models work so well why is over
parameterizing useful et cetera et
cetera so I think this is a fascinating
field but that's not what I'm focused on
so what what what I'm and actually this
is just an example actually that I um
that I I was last week I was in Santa
Barbara and I um
just just for fun I was just you know
stable diffusion you know a crocodile
surfing on a hamburger in Santa Barbara
and you you stick it in to this thing
and out comes pictures and I guess I
would have said I mean you know a couple
of years ago I think any of this would
have said that a a function that is able
to give you know a distribution of
answers like this is um is is
essentially impossible and now um you
know it's now they exist so um it's okay
but but I'm not interested in that I
mean actually I think that's very
interesting but I'm not interested in
that so the question that I want to ask
is and the main question I'm interested
in is whether or not the the the tools
and ideas that made things like that
possible also let us give us new ways of
attacking really core unsolved science
problems or physics problems of the sort
that we would have done ordinarily five
or ten years ago so that's what I want
to know
um the answer to and that's what we've
really been focusing on research program
and both actually at Harvard and at
Google
um and so so to that end I mean I think
that you know there's a lot that people
have been taking
um from the machine Learning Community I
mean there's lots of physics papers that
include neural networks in them in
various ways so I sort of care much less
about that I think that the um that to
me there are really two lessons that we
can learn from the machine Learning
Community
um as a from as a community of
scientists you know the first is really
the existence and the use of excellent
software Frameworks which include within
the native automatic differentiation
which will be what I will talk mainly
about today this basically allows makes
it possible to solve optimization
problems that you know um you know 20
years ago were just impossible I mean I
like probably many of you um you know
I've spent part of my life writing
adjoint codes trying to solve
optimization problems and it it um and I
mean I don't know if this will resonate
with any of you but to me like I
remember you know and maybe this this
dates me I you know when Matlab first
became when I first started I first
started using Mallet I used to write all
of my Matrix inverters myself basically
and you know I spent like a you know a
good number of years writing sparse
Matrix inverters to solve science
problems of A Sort that I wanted to and
then
um at some point you know I sort of
started to appreciate backslash as a as
a technology which essentially saved my
life I basically had to stop doing that
and I could start like solving problems
and I feel very much the same way with
these native automatic differentiation
framers it's like you know there are
lots of optimization problems that I
would love to solve and I think that
there are a lot that are relevant for
science problems all over the map and
that normally you know up until recently
we wouldn't have even asked the
questions that I'm going to ask in this
talk like I like you know I mean we I
mean we could have the questions existed
it's just that the um the the
possibility of answering them wasn't
there so so that's sort of one thing
that I think the machine Learning
Community has made possible and the
reason that there's been such a or at
least one of the reasons there's been
such rapid progress on things like
diffusion models for image generation is
because you know the the software
Frameworks are great they're they're
they make it possible to iterate ideas
very very quickly and for a community to
iterate ideas and to make progress so
the other thing which is important and
this I'm going to touch on last today
but I just wanted to say up front
because I would be curious is url's
perspective on this because you know you
you guys kind of like I mean I would
love to solve a complicated problem and
believe the answer
um but and you guys sort of do this all
the time and I think that what one thing
which is hard
um especially when solving optimization
problems of the sort that I'm going to
describe today is that is that you know
if I take a set of equations
um pdes Odes whatever some mathematical
model of a phenomena then of course we
can pose and solve optimization problems
on the solutions of that those equations
but the question of whether or not we
believe the model enough so that the
optimal solution actually has any
relevance whatsoever it is really open
and in many situations our models just
aren't good enough to basically do this
sort of thing and I think one of the
things that's impressed me about the
machine Learning Community is just how
careful they've been at setting up
benchmarks to measure accuracy for
important problems and to always measure
against the same benchmarks so that when
10 different groups work on a thing they
can all compare and it's routinely
compared solutions to each other which
because the advantage that one can then
iteratively improve things and I wish
this were true of models in the physical
sciences so I'm not going to talk about
this very much today but I just want to
put this out there in case anyone has
any interest in discussing is that I
just feel that like a lot of the
modeling that we the communities that
I'm aware of the physical sciences have
done over the years
um you know has the feature that it's
it's really great but it doesn't build
on itself in the same way that the ml
Community has done and I think that
there's really a lot that we can learn
from that and I mean just as an example
you know I mean this stable diffusion
thing is you some of you probably know
it's really very new it's a it just came
out and like you can go like this is
summer 2022 and like you can go right
now and you know they're open source
software Frameworks hugging face
basically you know they're just
beautifully written like you know
they're clearly explained it doesn't
require you know on one hand and then on
the other hand benchmarks like they're
always this is benchmarks from a month
ago of basically a large multimodal data
data set that's made to be open source
and the importance of this is that it
means that if anyone wants to compete
against tasks which lead to models like
this then there is a queen Benchmark
that you have to be or at least you can
compete on to do this and I wish this
were true I don't know I could invent a
problem I wish this were true if we're
modeling the Dynamics of a protein or
for modeling some complicated heat
transfer problem and I just and maybe
I'm ignorant and I would love to be
taught otherwise because I think again
you guys are I mean Livermore is one of
the places in the world that I see of as
being like the really the Brain Trust
for this kind of thing so if you you
know maybe this exists and I just
haven't noticed but to me it's it's like
everybody has their own model and there
isn't really um this sort of culture and
I feel like it's really slowed us down
actually and that we could if we could
figure out a way around it it could
really help anyway okay so that's my um
those are my things so um and um you
know and as I said before I mean that
our thesis isn't really the research
program I'm going to describe to you
about is that we think that these
lessons if we could apply them in the
hard science for hard science problems
we can make a lot of progress and that's
because you know for one thing and this
will be something I will touch on a lot
today is that there are lots of
non-convex optimization problems that I
at least would have never had the
courage to tackle or even formulate um
until recently and now it's something
that you know we can just try a
different one every day and try it in
different ways and it's really exciting
and I just wanna I'm just as a meta idea
I'm going to spend most of the time on
pdes but I sort of want to um mention
this as a motivation for my own research
group for things that we've been
thinking about and if this resonates
then you know I'm happy to discuss as
well is that one of the things we've
been interested in my research group at
Harvard over the last couple of years is
and what we call synthetic living
materials and the idea is is that like
if you look at biology and you look at
the phenomena that exists for materials
in biology
um they um the materials are made out of
Parts which have to be programmed um
both in terms of the way they interact
and the way that energy is fed to them
and when they do that then there are all
these kind of remarkable things that
happen you know microtubule assembly and
disassembly DNA proofreading you know
the assembly and disassembly of clathrin
cages and these are things that actually
in synthetic materials like we don't we
just don't know how to build materials
that are able to have this type of
functionality and so a question that
we've been struggling with for some time
is like how can we as a computational or
theoretical group come up with ways of
making design choices for experimental
implementations of materials to enable
functionality that emulates this and I
um and you know at the core of it there
are really two issues like one is can
one write down models that we believe
enough that we actually care about you
know an effort to optimate optimize them
to make an artificial microtubule like a
graduate student this morning was
showing me her model of an artificial
microtubule which is really quite fun
um and but but it's not it's it's sort
of it's practical enough that you could
imagine implementing it but yet
implementing it is still a problem
that's on one hand and you know then on
the other hand is can you find ways of
optimizing the um the large parameter
spaces that exist to basically enable
functionality and I think that this is
just an example of the types of
non-convex optimization problems that we
don't ordinarily solve and this is
driven you know a lot of our work in the
last couple of years and one of the
reasons I've gotten excited about
automatic differentiation is the
technology is because I think it gives
us a a new way of really addressing both
aspects of this which I will I may or
may not touch on in this talk but these
are just the big ideas of what I want to
say so benchmarks I already said this
about benchmarks you know have we given
up on accurately model actually this is
this would be a wonderful discussion
with all of you I just I wonder like you
know we have models
we accept the errors I mean maybe we
should be like the machine learning
people and really nail down them but
anyway that that's I I don't want to
it's okay so with that um said then this
is my outline and and I um this is far
too much material to cover but maybe um
this will give you a flavor for the
sorts of problems that we've been
working on so that if any of you are
interested if you just send me an email
then we can set up time to talk if it's
synergistic with things that are going
on at the lab I would love to discuss it
um but um but I'll I'm going to spend
most of my time on the third topic which
is
um discovering numerical algorithms for
pdes because I that this is in some ways
the most developed of the areas in our
own work but is um and I also I know
overlaps things happening with you guys
but I mean just to sort of give you
other things that we've been working on
is designing energy landscapes for
self-assembly so this involves you know
considering materials where one can
simulate or formulate the the ways that
they interact and then trying to figure
out if we can program them you know
either
um kinetically you know himself assembly
or not equilibrium or whatever so the
the design of non-equilibrium processes
is a topic of great interest I mean so I
mean for example one of the things that
that we've been doing and I will just
say this as an introduction and I
probably won't discuss it just for a
lack of time is that is that there's the
you know wonderful work by georgeinski
and Crooks on non-equilibrium
thermodynamics on forming um you know
looking for your formulating
optimization problems for minimizing
dissipative work and trying to find out
how to optimize near equilibrium
processes and the the challenge of that
work is that well I mean it's absolutely
gorgeous and beautiful and um but the
challenge is is that if you push it much
further out of equilibrium than just
linear response then the calculations
become very challenging to carry out
analytically which is the way that they
tend to be carried out and so one of the
things we've been doing is using
automatic differentiation to just
calculate automatically you to do
exactly what they're doing but to do it
at you wherever you want basically it
just doesn't matter it ends up being you
know like 20 lines of code or something
and I think that this is exciting
because it it just means that the sort
of intellectual framework that they've
set up could be applied more broadly
I'll touch on this so other things that
we've been thinking about again I won't
talk about them really but I'm
mentioning them to um
to um
um just to so people know what we're
thinking about is you know I've gotten
very interested with a visitor right now
at Harvard in designing reality I mean
the question of could you I mean if you
consider like multi-particle reality
could you tune the distribution of
particle sizes and interactions to
achieve rheological outcomes even
non-linear radiological outcomes and
this is something which and so this is
these are hard computational problems
and it's it's a hard optimization
problem but these are things that we're
starting to take on
um so another I'm set of problems which
I think is very interesting is
programming cells for tissue cell
division decision rules for tissue
development
um and um and then our model is good
enough so okay so that's my list of
topics I don't know you guys if anyone
has questions or wants to interrupt then
I really welcome comments I don't I know
that I I'm very conscious that I very
rarely make sense and so um
so I'll just keep going do you have
something are you you just special okay
so um so okay so automatic
differentiation I think I'm going to
assume that you all know what automatic
differentiation is I mean if if that's
okay I'm not gonna
um so so I mean automatic
differentiation is essentially a is
essentially a process in which one you
know as opposed to numerical
differentiation or symbolic
differentiation you know what we do with
Mathematica or
um you know Senpai or um just you know
doing numerical analysis in which one
takes a function unrolls the computation
graph of the function and then compiles
the function in such a way that using
the chain rule we know the both forward
and backward derivatives of the function
exactly and this is an idea that is is
old
um but that that recent machine learning
software has really um made much more
prevalent in open source
um in in open source libraries and um
you know the idea is I mean like I guess
I sort of you know at some point in my
youth as I'm sure with many of you I
fell in love with the adjoint method as
a way of optimizing for Solutions of
differential equations which you know of
course one implements by simply
considering if you have a set of
differential equations DX DT equals f of
x then what you do is is if you want to
optimize some loss function let's say
the loss function is just some function
of X of T then what you do is you add a
constraint that that that states that
the um that the um that the differential
equations are satisfied for X of T and
by doing this it essentially means that
you have to solve for the prices is that
you end up with an optimization problem
where you have to solve both the forward
problem for X of T and you have to solve
that turns out a backwards problem for
the adjoint Lambda ft but in so doing
this you end up being able to compute
derivatives of design variables in such
a way that it doesn't depend on the
number of design variables and or of
control variables and this is this is
very important because if you're you
know I mean if you're designing
materials which have many many many free
parameters you don't want to have to do
a forward solve every time you want to
take a derivative and this basically
makes it possible to do it on to do it
to get you know to have you know
algorithm to the scale so I sort of
spent part of my youth or even not use
you know coding these things like you
just if you want to solve something you
code the adjoint problem and some of you
might know who've done this it can take
a lot of work to basically code the
adjoint problem to be able to do this
and the amazing thing about these
automatic differentiation Frameworks at
least to me is that it just works
automatically As Long as You Follow
software rules so let me just give one
example of this which you know again I I
assume that you all know this better
than I do but in case you don't this is
just a plug of something so this is a
package which is called autograd that
was written by Ryan Adams in his group
um Ryan is now a Princeton but he used
to be my colleague at Harvard and he he
wrote it actually because it was in the
early days they were inventing graph
neural networks to study molecule
property prediction and you know I mean
you had to take the derivatives of
graphs and at the time this was in you
know this was more than a decade ago
when you know all these packages didn't
exist and they needed to write the code
and they decided they would just write
you know essentially a wrapper of numpy
which is what autograd was that
basically in you embedded automatic
differentiation into the solver and if
you go to their website which
still exists the GitHub site then you
know they have this example which I like
very much which is um which is basically
to find the initial conditions of a
velocity field of a flow so that when
you in fact the die which starts out you
know in this banded structure that it
ends up being a peace sign but
and it can be anything you want you can
put in any image and and the the thing
that I guess I just find amazing is that
this is the code that basically solves
this problem and so there's a simulate
function which you know solved there's
an induction projection
um you know there's some scheme for
basically solving the smoke so smoke is
effective of uh you have time so this
this simulates the smoke and then here's
the objective function so you take the
um you know the initial coordinates the
X and the Y you simulate them so final
smoke is simulate of the initial x v x
and v y which is what you're going to
optimize over the initial distribution
of the smoke which are those bands and
then some number of time steps and then
the objective function Returns the
distance from the target image of the
final smoke so this is just like an L2
loss of the peace sign and whatever the
solver got to and then you know with an
auto grad you just simply compute the
new function which is value and grad of
objective and it automatically returns
for you the derivative of the um of the
objective function with respect to its
parameters the parameters are the
initial velocities and then you can just
write a simple gradient descent
algorithm to find the answer and I guess
this is not rocket science or maybe
actually this is rocket science actually
but but this is not um that this is not
um complicated I mean this is something
we could have written this code whenever
any number of years ago but the point is
and this is the thing that I'm just so
struck by is that it couldn't be done so
easily and the reason why it's important
that it can be done easily is because it
makes it possible to experiment very
quickly with lots and lots of variants
of things which is I think important
basically in the physical sciences so so
this is what's impressed me so much and
and actually so autograd basically
um the as I said it was originally
written in Harvard and it's actually the
um the antecedent to Jack so there are a
bunch of packages for automatic
differentiation that have come out over
the years but Jax basically is just in
time
um
autograd and xla so autograd is the
middle part so the group that basically
is at Google you're responsible for Jack
started out the core part of the core
part of the group started out in Ryan's
group at Harvard and um and you know
because of the technological importance
of this then there's just tons of Open
Source tools that one can use to sort of
make this even better and this is just
an example of a function which I just I
mean I just find amazing this sort of
automatically parallelizes
um right
you know across gpus such calculations
when you're rolling out and when you're
rolling out simulations or things like
we do then you know it's just really
helpful to to have professionally
written things so okay so my other meta
comment before I talk about something
substantive is that you know of course
this was mainly developed from machine
learning this was really about machine
learning technology but the point is is
that you know architecturally dynamical
systems of whatever sort you want and a
machine learning model really have a lot
in common with each other I mean that is
at least in terms of computing gradients
of things like it's it's you know
they're both rolling out especially if
you roll out of an ecosystem that's like
pushing data through a neural network of
whatever architecture and I mean there
are differences in this that you know
are I mean I'm not claiming that these
problems are like these problems indeed
I think there's been a lot of effort in
the community on what it takes to solve
non-convex optimization problems in
traditional machine learning and there's
been much less effort in dynamical
systems and I think one of the things
that we as communities have to do is to
learn all of the tricks basically that
are required to basically really solve
problems in the space well but I think
that that's that's what I find exciting
so okay um and so let me see um okay so
that's my introduction I don't know does
anybody have anything to say
um or should I just plunge forth
okay so so what I'm going to do this is
really terrible you're going to see how
badly I designed this talk I'm
embarrassed but I think that this is
probably the right thing to do is I'm
going to just push through these two I'm
going to just flip through the slides
for number one and number two and I'm
gonna we're gonna talk about pdes and
then if anyone wants to talk about any
of the other things we can come back at
the end but I would rather make sure I
uncover something do a good job at one
thing instead of quickly going through a
bunch of things so um so let's see so um
sorry and this is like not equilibrium
processes not equal to a process
um
I think we'll be posted okay so
PDS so okay so so of course the
classical numerical algorithms that we
all know and love for pdes were
developed a long time ago and um you
know the traditional algorithm I mean
you all know better than I do so I
apologize for um but but you know
basically you know we take the pde
whatever it is and we discretize it and
we then turned it into an update rule um
where we predict the state of the system
at for the degree of freedom I which
could be a mesh point or it could be
some spectral basis thingy or whatever
you want you know at time n plus one as
a function of the earlier time steps and
if you if you take this update rule then
what we do of course numerically is we
roll out this update rule
um giving the you know giving the
Dynamics and as you all know there's you
know a tremendous literature in the
derivation and the implementation of
update rules but but traditionally these
update rules are learned by um are
um
are things that you that that
um that we derive basically
um so um but but no but nonetheless and
I mean I think this is just the reality
which again if anyone disagrees with
this I welcome
please disagree I mean you know
we've made a tremendous amount of
progress I mean I think you know you
guys I mean the work that you all do is
is stunning you know how much we can
simulate
um in in the modern day but still you
know we still can't afford
um even today to simulate you know very
simple situations and and there are and
I think there's just any uh and this is
just you know turbulent flow is sort of
emblematic of the problem but it's not
obviously the only problem I mean if you
simply count the number of Como graph
Eddies in a box of size L then that the
number of any scales like the Reynolds
number to the nine quarter power and
what that means is if you say and I know
that this is an overstatement but if you
say that every Eddie needs a thousand
grid points to resolve it it's a 10
cubed then you end up with a formula for
the total number of good points you need
which is you know a thousand maybe you
would argue it was a hundred but
whatever times Reynolds number is the
nine fourths and if you start putting in
Reynolds numbers of reasonable
situations you just run out of memory
very quickly and and you know this is
something like you know it wasn't
possible you know when annoyman you know
and people like that started thinking
about it and it basically will never be
possible to simulate these things I
think that this is you know we shouldn't
forget what a problem this is I mean
it's a um it's something that we're
obviously all I'm working to fix but but
it's a fundamental problem in our view
that the world that these equations are
fundamental basically and you you know
so an example you know of this is if you
if you consider a weather model so this
is the typical numerical resolution in a
weather model and
um I mean this resolution I mean it's
not bad I mean you can see the hurricane
but on the other hand you know there's a
lot of microscopic processes that are
happening inside of each of these boxes
and the fact that we're not resolving
that means that there are errors and
what the nature of the errors are of
course is what you know many of us work
on but but it's not a pretty
um situation so okay so that's on one
hand so now on the other hand imagine
the following and this is you know a
good Duncan experiment in a way imagine
I told you that these curves were
solutions to some pde and I didn't tell
you what pde they were
um and I asked you to solve them
numerically so what you would do
according to traditional schemes is you
choose some number of grid points and
you will notice that here just for
illustrations cake steak I've chosen too
few because I'm only having one grid
point at the shock basically which
obviously is not what we want to do we
then take the solution away we then need
to to use the differential equations we
need to compute the derivatives of the
function at every one of these points
and so what we do what we were all
taught When We Were Young is that what
we should do is we should interpolate
this somehow and so I don't know suppose
you were trained badly you would use
some sort of polynomial interpolation
and then of course there's the
well-known phenomenon that is
Illustrated here where you know it gives
you the wrong answers basically because
and it's precisely because the grid is
under-resolved and the derivative of
this function at this point is not what
it should be because we're interpolating
with functions that that basically under
fit the data so you know on the other
hand suppose that I told you something
different I basically gave you the
points and I said listen I'm not
interested in building solvers that work
for any equation it turns out just as a
Duncan experiment the only equation I
care about is Burger's equation and
actually these curves were Solutions of
burglar's equation and moreover he here
is a large library of solutions Burgers
equations that I put together that you
can use when you're trying to compute
derivatives so if you're given the
problem in this way then it shouldn't be
a problem anymore I mean you can
basically look at this point you're not
going to overfit like this there's no
overshoots in these Solutions you're
going to sort of fit this with a
hyperbolic tense or something which
actually turns out to be the answer
right and try to estimate the derivative
that way and you will do much better and
so that is to say that there's another
view of solvers which is that instead of
deriving the equations from first
principles that we can imagine solving
the equations at high resolution
learning what happens when we under
resolve and then using those learnings
to try to feed into the update rule for
the solver and this is essentially what
we set out to do and this is an example
of something that with automatic
differentiation is actually not so hard
to do without it would be a nightmare
and so let me just sort of show you how
this works so the method the method
basically goes like this we perform many
high resolution simulation of small
pieces of the solution we then train an
algorithm to to find an update rule to
match the high resolution the average of
the high resolution Solution on a
coarser grid so that's the that's the
way that the algorithm
goes now this is
um I mean I just stated it in words it's
a you can easily turn the words into an
optimization problem and in order to
solve it though you have to be able to
do something which is like the smoke
thing that I showed you at the beginning
is that you're we're now not tuning over
initial conditions we're going to be
tuning over the parameters in the update
we're all trying to match basically high
resolution parts of the solution and the
question is is this useful and does this
work so okay so let me um let me just
explain what I mean by averaging so this
is an example of infection of a scalar
by by a sort of chaotic flow this is a
high resolution solution this is an
exact coarse graining of high resolution
solution so that what this did is we
simply just took little boxes of this
size and average the solution so this is
so the question is I mean there are two
questions is could you so given the
exact solution and you know here's the
course grain solution because you invent
a timestampering algorithm that
basically gives you this so that the way
that this was produced was that we took
the high resolution solution and we
averaged that's the question is it does
such an algorithm exist even for large
degrees of course granting and so so
that's the question that we kind of went
after and I guess what what I wanted to
say is that you all know this I mean
classical numerical analysis if you take
a class is that typically doing this
using just simply using the laws of
calculus that we were taught When We
Were Young to derive the algorithms
doesn't work at doing this if that's how
you design the algorithm it doesn't work
because basically the um they're either
instabilities that occur this is like
with a typical finite volume method
which is pushed on a coarser grid and or
you can use a fancy flux limiter or
something which is which is better at
maintaining stability but it has too
much diffusion and it smears the thing
out and so so that's and so the question
again that we wanted to ask was whether
or not this could be sorted out and so
to do this we invented the following
algorithm and let me just show it to you
in terms of this training procedure so
basically what we did was I want you to
focus on this box so normally do you
know the the there's some number of
points where you know the velocity field
where you're trying to compute the
derivative and you might use some
interpolation method to compute the
derivative so what we did is we
pretended that these interpolation
coefficients CNM K are coefficients that
are learned basically by the solver and
so we're not going to drive these from
calculus although when we did what I'm
about to show you we imposed constraints
on them that they agree with you know
accuracy constraints at some level but
we we allowed we allowed them to get
learned we then took these for these
derivatives we we computed fluxes we
then wrote down a traditional time
stepping scheme you know a simple finite
volume time stepping scheme and so of
course if you wanted to just roll this
out then what you would do is you would
just go around this Loop and that's the
that's the update rule but you can also
train it because what you can do is you
can
go through this and and then you can
compute a loss so the loss is going to
be it's going to depend on these
coefficients C sub K but these
coefficiencies of K are really
parametrized by the weights of the
neural network and what we're going to
do is ask whether an algorithm exists
that does what I just said and this is
something which if you have an auto diff
code then you can easily run and so okay
so I'm going to show you this first on
the first thing we did and this is the
sort of simplest thing to try is to try
this on Burger's equation so this is a
paper that was published a couple of
years ago and just to sort of show you
how this works
um when you this is a solution to
Burger's equation this black the dash
curve actually
um the the black is the numerical
discretization and what these These are
showing you these things are these are
stencils for the first derivatives for
um
that Essentials for the first derivative
of the scheme that is learned and these
change as you go across the solution so
if you're in this part which is kind of
the smooth part of the solution it
reverts back to what you would have
derived because of the way that we've
set this up but when you're in the Steep
part it does something completely
different basically it's just a
different scheme that the model has
learned and so then when you time step
it's just learn schemes to basically
affect the shock basically and so so we
did this and this is sort of showing you
an example this is a chimerograph so
this has X on this axis t on this axis
so this is unrolling a solution to
Berger's equation this is a um unrolling
this is rolling it out on a on a mesh
spacing that's 32 times bigger than the
the mesh facing where the data was
generated and we trained on a domain of
size 2 pi so this was the size of a
training domain and then what we did is
we rolled out on this entire thing and
then you can ask you know how accurate
is it so like is this accurately rolling
out broker's equation this thing would
have destabilized if you'd use the
classical method and basically if you
plot mean absolute error as a function
free sample factor resample factor is
how many grid points are you skipping I
was showing you the 32 one if you
compare basically our method which is
these solid blocks to you know other
classical methods then um
then you know we outperform all of them
and interestingly enough so the we know
method is the um sort of best at least
to my knowledge although there may be
people in the room who know much better
the best known method which is was of
course a method that was invented you
know maybe 20 years ago and that is is
very sophisticated in terms of its
derivation so Just for kicks we asked
the model if it could learn a single
scheme right you're not changing at
every point of the solution but a single
scheme that could be applied everywhere
and we demanded that it had that and the
model because you can ask it to do that
and it essentially reproduced the
accuracy of the windows scheme which is
kind of fun
um and um so this this thing basically
works so that was that and we then
in this paper which was published a
couple of years ago we tried it on a
bunch of other canonical one dpds and
said like maybe this is not a stupid
idea now of course as you all know you
know it's if you come up with an idea
then you know testing it on 1D problems
is the right thing to do but that's not
I mean the world is is not dimensional
so okay so then
um so a year ago we published this paper
which was with the group at Google
basically so I want to Stefan Hoyer and
Dima koshkoff Jamie Smith is actually
now a graduate student at Stanford she
was an AI resident at Google for a while
in which we we basically took this idea
and tried to apply it to computational
fluid dynamics and let me just sort of
show you what it is and this is again a
model this is a simple problem in
computational fluid mechanics but this
is trying to get at the the thing so so
okay so for this what we're going to do
is now we're going to take the full oh
good there's a question
um
um I I can't I'm not sure in fact I'm
what's the input I I can't okay so clear
uh asked what's the input of the neural
network to get those scheme coefficients
yeah so okay so the input so let me just
go back to
this so let me just go back to this
picture I'm sorry I'm going quickly so
the input are the velocity field on the
course mesh within some vicinity of the
point where you want to compute the time
derivative so it's just like a classical
scheme right
some numbers
the higher order method around those
number of points but if the points are
not close together then there are the
well-known problems but we feed those
points at the mess spacing they're into
the neural network which is what
computes the seeks okay and there's some
you know domain of dependence that one
assumes so it's just like you always do
it's just that now these coefficients
are non-linear functions of the use that
you have to learn
so I'll talk about this a little more
when we do the turbulence because I
think turbulence is much more
interesting because it is much more
relevant so okay um so thanks for the
question so um
so okay so um so okay so turbulence so
again so what we seek is we want to
solve the number six equations we seek
an update Rule and Just for kicks and
again I I we want to seek an update rule
such that the course grid matches the
fine grid but it reduced and also
actually this I didn't emphasize before
what we really want is for this to work
at reduced computational cost because
one thing I didn't emphasize and what I
just showed you is that of course if
you're putting the the mesh points
through a neural network you have to pay
for that at every mesh point and if it
ends up costing you more than it would
have cost you to to run the initial high
resolution simulation you're just
wasting your time basically so so I'm
now going to be much more careful about
this in this part of the talk and and
we'll talk about computational costs um
so okay so we're looking for an update
Rule and this this is really a different
type of solver to my knowledge than
those that have this is like a DNS
solver but it's a it's a DNS solver for
which the resolution is much lower than
it normally has to be and actually the
other thing I want to emphasize though
because I I do want to to stay getting
back to 20 000 just to make them at a
point is that you know the beauty of
this is that this is a particular goal
that we chose to go after which I think
is a natural goal but you could do
whatever you want with this technology
like I mean there are lots of things you
could choose instead of this and I think
this is one of the reasons I'm so
excited about this as an area is that I
just feel like you know creativity it's
like if you don't have to write your own
Matrix inverters anymore
so okay so traditionally
so there isn't the goal of getting porn
as a point-wise agreement approaches
instead one tries to produce a
correction to the update rule that
basically statistics and so you know an
Les paper is 110.
things like
extraordinarily useful practically I
want to emphasize that what we're doing
here it's like an Les method it it's but
we're demanding points
ending more usually and which is used
for
this
hey Michael
um I I guess it's not only me I thought
it was only me but
um
uh Michael your internet seems to be
unstable can you can you hear me
hi Michael
oh that's unfortunate
um
actually let me try to stop my video
maybe that helps
um
hi Michael
[Music]
which is just a word but this is another
thing you could do hi Michael can you
can you hear me yes please yeah we we
kind of lost you about a I don't know
one or two minutes past oh you asked me
two minutes that's bad what happened
I don't know maybe your internet
connection was unstable so maybe you can
you can go back a little bit okay I'm
really sorry maybe you can you can turn
off turn off the camera
okay I'm sorry how do I turn off the
camera there's a start video and a
button at the bottom or since you are
sharing a screen yeah yeah
sorry uh how do I do this video got it
okay exactly hopefully that makes it
okay sorry where should I start I
apologize for that thank you for telling
me yeah if yeah this slide if you can
start over this okay sorry everybody I
apologize and something always goes
wrong so please if I if that happens
again say I had no idea um okay so so I
mean traditional yes models are
different than the type of model that I
described because what you do is change
the update rule by adding an effective
viscosity term or something to it for
which you emulate the statistics of the
actual solution even if you're
um you're solving on a course on a
course of grid and the difference
between this and the scheme that we're
exploring is that our Explorer our
scheme is trying to get on average
pointwise accuracy I'm not making an
argument that one is better than the
other I think they're different and I
think what's interesting here is just
the ability to go after the type of
scheme that we're going as an example of
which as I said before there are many
there are many other things when could
imagine doing but this is just an
example so okay so update rules so I
want to emphasize that if you're trying
to build update rules so this relates to
the question you know
what you could do is derive an update
rule which just makes the whole thing a
neural network so you could have the
Velocity at time n plus one it's just a
function at previous times where you you
know enforce causality so that every
Point only takes in its neighbors when
trying to figure out how it's update but
you simply let a machine learning
um you you know um
figure out what the form of G is like
that that's a perfectly reasonable
update rule to derive and this is
something this is an emulator basically
this is this is a type of
of structures
um you know under one under exploits in
many places including um I know people
Livermore who are doing this I think
it's a very interesting thing for many
reasons but so that's pure machine
learning so the the second thing you
could do and this is what I was talking
about with the brokerage equation
example is what you do is you take the
velocity field and you in you put it
into a neural network which essentially
does interpolation for you and you then
take that and put that into the normal
equations of motion but on a coarser
grid to derive the update rule so that's
that and and then and this is this is
sort of what the architecture is for
what I'm about to show you I mean we
basically stick the velocity field into
internal Network we um compute basically
we interpolate the non-linear terms in
every structure equations we interpolate
the fluxes basically onto the midpoints
of the cells that's the part that we we
use machine learning for and um and then
we just you know project under
Divergence free fields and time step and
we can insert the force and so this is
an example of inserting machine learning
but keeping the physics the basic
structure of the of Newton's laws are
still there and and then the third thing
you could imagine doing which I think is
also interesting is you could take the
velocity field you could put it into
your discretization that we always did
and then you could say oh no there's a
mistake and add a correction to it and
um and
um and use that and so these are three
very different things we call this one
learned Corrections and and so the point
we want to make is there's no Theory
there's no principle that says one of
these is better than the other and I
think one of the challenges that
actually exists or one of the questions
that exists in the field of people doing
this right now is to figure out in what
situation which of these is better and
how and and what I want to what I'm
going to show you is kind of an effort
to do this in one problem so um so okay
so when you say better though you have
to be careful we have to be very careful
about what we mean so better means there
are two different axes of the word the
better one is accuracy and the other is
generalizability so accuracy is what
I've been talking about you know the in
our case right now reproducing DNS with
with the courser matched with bigger
timestamps oh I forgot to say actually
that we the way we've coded this thing
when we increase the mesh spacing we
assume a current condition with the um
I'm stepping and so our time step is
scaled with the space step with the core
State space step so we actually increase
the time step in concordance with up
when we do what I'm about to show you
and also what I showed you before so but
accuracy is one important thing
important thing is generalizability and
of course the reason that we all love
the laws of physics is because the
beauty of them is you can solve them for
whatever problem you want and you will
they will work right and they always
work basically and so um and this is
something which if you train a pure
machine learning model this is gone
basically I mean generalizability is
gone because you you will only
generalize if you've given it you know
the situations that it knows to learn
the rules on and and so there's really a
tension between these two things and
this is I think part of what's
interesting here and so what we did
basically I think this one which is as
I'll show you a 2d turbulence problem is
to adopt
um different types of generalization
tests so we one generalization test is
to basically consider
um a flow where the forcing is the same
it's a turbulent flow but we have
different random initial conditions this
is a rather popular
um test that people who train machine
learning models do I I personally find
it to be quite weak and the reason is is
because if you're studying any problem
that is complicated then it will be the
solutions will be chaotic and if they
are chaotic then we all know that
there's really up enough time Beyond
which essentially the the Dynamics
becomes uncorrelated with the initial
conditions anyway and so randomizing the
initial conditions is not so different
than just being able to simulate forward
in time and so it's almost the same
thing so I mean this is a consistency
check but I'm not sure how impressive
this is so another thing you could do is
change the forcing function and then the
sort of strongest test and what I'm
going to show you is to actually take a
model that was trained in one Reynolds
number or a set of rentals numbers and
you use the scaling laws that we know
from the theory of turbulence to to
change to different Reynolds numbers so
okay so here are the tests so what we
used and what I'm about to show you is
coma graph flow so this is 2D turbulent
flow that's forced with komogorov
forcing which is just a canonical
forcing function to drive
um flow and the generalization test that
I will show you include both enlarging
the domain and also turning on the
forces like changing the forcing and
also changing the Reynolds number so
taking a model trained at one Reynolds
number and going to another random
number so okay so in order to do the
work I'm about to show you we wrote a
fully differentiable fluid solver in Jax
so this um it's a it's a finite volume
code and and um and it basically makes
it easy to do the sort of thing that I'm
going to show you and I mean just as an
example so here's a gif of the of a
simulation of a turbulent flow and you
know it's object oriented and so you can
just sort of roll out trajectories
anyway I'm not going to belabor this but
this is open source and so people can
play with it if they want
um so okay so here's the um here's the
study so what we did what I'm going to
show you is komogorial flow with the
Reynolds number of a thousand
um we took ground troops trajectories
from a high resolution was 20 foot
square and with each time step obeying
the CFL condition with a scaling factor
of a half we've hit these
he took 30 trajectories with different
random seeds
yep did something happen
yeah yeah it seems to be broken again uh
maybe
I don't know what I'm really sorry you
think it's my internet
let me
you you can't can you hear me yeah I can
hear you so you can restart this slide
again I guess okay yeah yeah I'm really
sorry I don't know what's I'm really
sorry everybody no worries things can
happen
so okay so um so what we did was we um
we Uma Garofalo with Reynolds number
1000 and we took um ground suits
trajectories from a high resolution
simulation that was 2048 squared where
each time step obeyed the CFL condition
with a factor of a half we then down
sampled this to coarser grids to be used
as trading data
um to train it we use 32 trajectories
with different random seeds we unrolled
for 4 800 time steps
um where the time step was modified to
obey the CFL condition on the
downsampled grid and we then trained it
with an L2 loss in which we unrolled
over 32 time steps so that's so we
didn't just on we didn't predict only
the next time step we found that when we
did that that the resulting scheme was
unstable but that by increasing the
number of time steps in the loss then um
then that basically allowed us to find
stable models that could be rolled out
for very long so model evaluation
actually was the most expensive part of
this process we generated much longer
trajectories
um you know tens of thousands of steps
and to make sure that the model was
stable over a long time and and so
that's basically what we did and now I'm
going to show you a couple of results so
this is um this is a this is a DNS of
2048 squared and I've put in here
there's a box which shows you a
turbulent structure which you can track
as you go through different time steps
and this is plotting vorticity in two
Dimensions so the the the
um the direct simulation that's been
downscaled to 64 squared is at the
bottom and what you see is that this
initial structure
um still exists after 500 steps
participates after a thousand steps
whereas in the learn solver which is the
middle row it still tracks perfectly and
actually you see a slight discrepancy
here but but
um but remember the flow is also chaotic
so okay so putting making this sort of
into into into a picture but this plots
the vorticity correlation with respect
to
um you know as a function of time with
respect to the ground truth solver
um this vertical dashed line is the um
is the is three liab enough times and um
and this is basically different
um so this is the Learned interpolation
as the dashed line which is 64 squared
and this is the 64 Square direct solve
and these are direct solves at different
resolutions this is 2-48 this is 10 24
and this is 512 and so what you see is
that the 64 Square large interpolation
is performing at a level which is
basically in between 512 and 10 24. so
it's performing like a much higher
resolution grid it it um it starts to
peel off at around three liab enough
times which is you know basically the
best you can expect
um to do so now the reason why and this
is the same sort of comparison actually
of accuracy looking at Spectra instead
of instead of looking at um Spectra at
long times instead of looking at
um just matching times and inspector are
useful because at very long times you
want to make sure this scheme is getting
this is physics right and this basically
just demonstrates that the that the
learn scheme is getting the statistics
right at the same level as the higher
resolution schemes
um so okay so the interesting thing is
that so if you run this on a a TPU V4
then um then the um then we have 12.5
higher flops than the Baseline cfd
solver because of course we're we're
running these neural networks to compute
the interpolation schemes as we're going
and so the utilization fraction the
machine is higher and so despite that
means that despite having 150 times more
operations the mlbase solver is only 12
times slower than the Baseline cfd
solver and so
um the the grid spacing basically
difference I mean actually I didn't so
the the grid spacing actually you could
maintain accuracy by upscale while
upscaling the grid by a factor of 10.
and so what that means is that if you if
you compute the the speed up the speed
up is 10 cubed right it's 10 squared
because of two dimensions and there's
another factor of 10 because of the
timestamping and then you have to divide
by 12 because that's the cost of the ml
soluble and so this is raw 80 times
faster than the um than the um than than
the direct solve and so this actually is
is I don't know we think kind of
interesting and when we plot basically
the um the um the sort of Pareto
Frontier right the the run time per time
unit as a function of the time until the
solution degrades
um then basically what we see is is that
that there's over a range of resolutions
about a a 90 times speed up this
actually is a slight underestimate we
found later on but anyway so but that's
the um that that's the the result and um
so and then we we took the same solver
when we ran a bunch of generalization
tests so this is decaying turbulence
where you see that the thing still works
so this is the DNS this is the Learned
interpolation and this is the direct
solver which loses the structures rather
quickly we did a test at higher Reynolds
number so this is what we did is we took
a simulation at rounds number four
thousand so in two Dimensions the common
graph scale scales like one over the
square root of the Reynolds number so
the difference between Reynolds number a
thousand and four thousand the
Commonwealth scale should Factor go down
by a factor of a half so what we
therefore did is took the model that we
learned at Reynolds number 1000 we cut
the mesh spacing by a half and we simply
use the same model and found out that it
worked also on on um so this is 4096
this is 128 squared with this model so
it's not quite as good as the other one
this is between you know 512 and 256 but
it's still right um you know allows
substantial upscaling
and this is a larger domain test which
which works
um as well and um and then finally and
then I'm almost out of time I knew this
was going to happen so I will stop in
two minutes but then finally what we did
is we took all of the different types of
models that I described at the beginning
and we can put them against each other
so we took um you know learned the
Learned interpolations which I've just
gone through carefully we took the learn
Corrections which you can sort of easily
do as well and then we took two types of
ml models these are just different
architectures that people use and we ran
them across all of these benchmarks and
this is the result this is a very messy
slide but I but there's a lot of compute
in this side I think there's one point
so each row is a different forcing so
this is the force turbulence that we use
to train larger domain decaying and more
turbulent and these are different
metrics Point wise accuracy statistical
accuracy and stability and um and these
are the different models so learned
interpolation learn correction and these
are the two pure machine learning models
of resnet oops
um an epd just another architecture
basically what you see is that on the
force turbulence some of the machine
learning models especially with this epd
architecture do perform at the same
level as the um train models that is you
can get pure ml models that that have
the same accuracy and stability as the
um as the models that we trained using
the physics-based ways but as soon as
you start changing the task and making
it harder
um you know
um the you know especially changing the
forcing a larger domain or increasing
the Reynolds number then the
physics-based models outperform and the
ml models don't generalize as well and I
think this is exactly what you would
expect and this is exactly the tension
that I think that our community has to
really try to understand is that there
are going to be some places where
emulators are actually great and um but
then they're going to be other places
where actually including aspects of the
physics and the solver is going to
actually produce just better answers
that generalize and the ones you're out
if two oh
um I'm going to just like that
um tell you this is an artwork of the um
of the the work I've just shown you and
then I'll show you one more summary
slide on just general auto diff so I
mean with respect to this pde solving so
we're still in the early days
um but um but but basically the the
scaling if you if you think so the
runtime scale is like n over K to the D
plus one this is an explicit solver so n
is the number of mesh points um K is the
effective course grading Factor you can
find you can get away with basically and
then there's a pre-factor here which the
C physics comes from normal physics
models and this is the ml overhead so
right now in our hands this ratio of CML
to C physics is 12.
um if you assume that 10x decrease in
resolution generalizes to 3D then this
number
um then the speed up goes to from a
thousand to ten thousand
um
you know instead and I mean although
this doesn't solve of the intractable
scaling problem I talked about the
beginning you know every factor of a
thousand the joke is that every factor
of a thousand
um kind of helps so so this is actually
I think kind of interesting and there's
a lot to be done so we the Google group
actually is now working on a GCM so I'm
not going to talk about this but just to
sort of say it which is I think another
fun thing and then finally in the rest
of my crazy number of topics which you
can see how crazy it is I mean we've
been we've actually been having a lot of
fun recently with the visitor at Harvard
designing biology using Jack cfd
modifications of it to allow us
boundaries and this is really fun at
that time to talk about it
so this is a picture of my research
group at Harvard and people have
contributed to this way of thinking
um and these are people I mean I want to
put up these are the people um who were
really responsible for the work that I
um talked about here and um maybe at
this time for a couple of questions
thank you and I apologize
thank you um all right it seems to be
broken again but uh thank you so much
Michael a wonderful talk I was I'm very
inspiring
um at the same time
um so let's have a q a session
um if you have any questions please
uh put that in the chat or mute yourself
and okay so the question from Amin he
asked about could you please comment on
steady state problems where there is no
update rule to optimize using ml how
would you go about it
yeah so I mean I mean can you give me an
example
um any time independent problem like um
so you all the examples you have shown
is the time dependence problem
I talked about time dependent update
rules I didn't talk about you know
solving a process equation or you know
solving steady state heat transfer
problems or things like that
um so I think that's an interesting
question I mean you know one one sort of
obvious comment I mean the answer is I
don't really know to be honest but just
but because you know we're trained to
always answer questions even when we
don't know I mean one obvious comment of
course is that if you were talking about
steady state heat transfer then you know
I mean you could learn the operator from
the from the time dependent problem and
then use the steady state version of it
to try to learn the steady state state
problem so that's certainly one thing
that you could imagine doing you know um
otherwise I mean I think that you could
imagine formulating steady state
problems in this way if you wanted
there's a lot of I mean there's a lot of
room I'm happy to talk about it I mean
sorry I'm not sure I answered your
question
all right actually I mean uh posted
earlier another questions he asked about
this sincere constant optimized form
matches that we know the time integrated
scheme could that Loosely mean that we
know is theoretically the lower limit
for a fixed stencil I mean I think that
that's certainly what this suggests I
mean we didn't try to match winner
that's just what happened
so um
so I think that this suggests that all
right sounds good uh next question is by
Bruce Shelley he asked about could you
please briefly again explain where is
the automatic differentiation and the
numerical solution used in Europe the
way that the automatic differentiation
is using is remember that we've defined
the update rule so it depends on
parameters which which aren't known
initially they're the weights of the
neural networks that are used for the
interpolation functions and so we then
Define a loss function which is you know
to make the update rule so that it has
the property that I describe and you
have to optimize the loss function with
respect to the weights basically so in
order to do that you have to roll out
this this the update rule in time and
you then have to take the derivative of
the loss with respect to the weights and
that is where the automatic
differentiation is used is that the
optimization is done with gradient
descent you know some Optimizer that's a
gradient based optimizer so I don't know
if that makes sense but that's
um okay
sounds good okay so that's by P what
makes the ml model generalizable to
different Reynolds number right so the
generalization that I showed you was
from one thousand to four thousand and
there we simply used you know the
asymptotics of the turbulent Cascade
right you know the chromograph scale has
a scaling with Reynolds number and
essentially what the scheme that I was
describing does we believe is that it's
essentially learning as it were the
structure of the smallest Eddy in the
comical f scale and letting you
represent it with less points and in
that Spirit since as the Reynolds number
increases then you know if you believe
in the theory of turbulence then it
tells you that that there's universality
and so you should be able to just
rescale by the you know one over the
square root of Reynolds number in 2D or
you know um what is it it's the Reynolds
number it's the three quarters power or
whatever it is in 3D um one over anyway
whatever it is the um the the um and
then you should be able to rescale and
apply different Reynolds number and we
we didn't you could actually use this as
a training procedure actually there's
lots of things you could do we just
checked that it worked from 1040
thousand which it did I think that you
could make a generalizable model of a
Reynolds number I think there's work
that needs to be done there to sort of
to do it definitively but I think it
could be done and I think even in
principle extrapolative and I think
what's actually interesting is could you
do this and um you know maybe let's
let's do the largest DNS that's ever
been done and let's do it by generating
training data up to some Reynolds number
and then extrapolating to a larger one
demonstrating that it works and then you
know running a larger computer compute
that you could do before so I think
there's room basically oh yeah so the
the follow the next question is is
related
uh Andre he asked about how difficult
would it be to apply the method to
higher Reynolds number like 10 to the
6th or 10 to the eighth power yeah so I
mean I think in principle this is this
is there's nothing in principle that's
part that's wrong this is the only thing
that limited our Reynolds number was
that um Jack CFT right now runs on a
single TPU or GPU and so you'd have to
operate attribute a version of the code
but there's nothing about the um
other than that there's nothing that
when it's I mean you know it's the same
as always right right okay so uh another
question uh from Amin have you compared
your method with a pure ml uh approach
but using a physics informed loss
function such as that residual of the
pde yeah yeah so I should say so this is
a longer conversation so I must admit I
these physics informed laws functions I
am confused by maybe that's the right
way to say it um so I think that you
know all of numerical analysis is about
designing algorithms which minimize as a
you know the residual of the pde and so
you know if you're parameterizing if
you're using the neural network to
parametrize the the nodes of the
solution and then you can certainly do
that and use automatic differentiation
to do that but what I'm describing is I
think quite different than that so I
think there's a longer conversation I
don't want to go too quickly but I'd
happy to discuss that but it's um I
don't actually think that the two are
comparable and I think for one thing the
parameter efficiency of the of the sorts
of method that you're describing I think
is much worse than the ones that I'm
describing and I don't think it's going
to compare well because
um but there's a longer conversation so
yeah yeah
all right another question is by Faye
what if the ground truth is noisy can
you differentiate through the suite yeah
I think that's a good question I mean
you could of course create a loss
function that's not L2 you could create
some sort of a probabilistic loss
function there's a lot of room there the
part of the talk that I didn't give was
about
um differentiating through Solutions of
longevon equations that we're describing
materials assembly processes and and
which is something that we do routinely
and so that in that case the ground
truth is noisy and what
you know created on some average we
batch them and then we and then we ask
so there's so there's room
okay sounds good okay another question
is by Kian is there an opportunity to
interpret the ml skin to design adaptive
numerical schemes
um there is but I I think that that I
mean I think that the we know example is
an interesting one of that we didn't go
into that today but I mean it'll be
interesting to see if it would reproduce
we know or if it would reproduce
something which one could then go and
derive that would be cool but we haven't
gone down that road but I think that
it's interesting all right sounds good
uh a question from me I don't see any
more questions in the chat room so you
know the the example you showed in the
influence ml inference the cost was a 12
times slower than the um you know the
traditional uh one and I guess you can
optimize that uh try to minimize that
first by you know exploring exploring
the structure of the neural net Etc I
guess you
there's a lot of room there we haven't
worked under it at all so that this is
the thing this is the 12th is the number
that came out of what we did and we
didn't try that at all and as you know
there's been you know in general there's
been a lot of progress trying to create
smaller models that have the same
accuracy as a larger models so there's
no reason not to be bullish about the
ability to push that number down I have
no idea how much it can be pushed down
there's no reason not I think there's no
reason there's every reason to think
that can be improved yeah okay the next
question is kind of related uh from
Prana but what are some approaches
simply to select optimal hyper
parameters yes it's I guess same answer
yeah it's an answer there all right next
next question is by key does people work
on something similar to in the context
of a high order finite elements where
the operators are generally less Bandy
yeah I think that's a really interesting
question I don't know if anyone is I
think it's a really interesting
Direction
um okay
all right uh is there any other question
from audiences
having Corner yeah
please unmute
all right so can you hear me yeah yeah
okay so first of all really interesting
talk I've started working with some of
these automatic differentiation methods
recently and I think that there's a lot
of application
um so one thing that you you mentioned
at the very beginning I was just kind of
wondering because I haven't quite had
the time to sit down to this stuff is
you know using an automatic
differentiation toolbox to basically get
around using Agilent methods for
sensitivity analysis yeah
um what's the general trade-off there
so is it time compute resources memory
um is
I mean there's actually a memory I mean
certainly you know I mean the problem is
if you if you're unrolling with
automatic differentiation then you're
storing the entire computation the
partial derivatives on the entire
computation graph which if you're
writing an adjoint a general adjoint you
tend not to you can sort of get around
it basically by making it more efficient
so so there is for sure a trade-off but
on the other hand you you know
um the two are quite synergistic and at
least for me I don't I haven't written
that joint codes for a while because of
this
yeah because I mean there's always the
question also of um you know I also like
I was wondering what your thought on
this was because you could you could see
two different approaches to using
something like automatic differentiation
you can do sort of these large massive
problems where just writing derivatives
by hand is completely unfeasible yeah or
you can all and you can also take the
interpretation and these are not
completely independent of just like
using automatic differentiation as a
rapid prototyping tool yeah yeah no I
agree with I agree with this
um I mean I think that the um and I
unfortunately after I'm a citizen I
unfortunately have to run because I'm
like I'm sorry yeah just another thing
but I'm happy having to talk about this
more because I think this is interesting
I mean you know the point The Meta point
I was trying to make was more the
automatic the the rapid prototyping tool
I feel like if you don't have to rewrite
the code every time you want to try
something new then it makes it easier to
try new things and when you figure out
the right one then we can always write
efficient code however we want around it
but it's the trying new things that
especially when you're in this
non-convex optimization who knows what's
going to work what kind of scheme is
going to be stable what's going to be
useful in the world I just feel like
that's the part that at least I find
exciting I know it's kind of boring in a
way like rapid prototyping as a reason
to do science well but I just feel like
it's it's a it's certainly a reason that
the machine Learning Community has moved
so quickly and I just again wonder what
our Affinity could do with it if we
thought about things this way yeah yeah
thank you very much okay all right thank
you thank you so much
yeah let's let's thank our speaker is
awesome thank you so much for thanks
everybody you know yeah thank you thank
you goodbye give me if you have
questions bye all right bye